greenpeace on l'a fait une spécialité
les actions coup de poing pour une
couverture médiatique la plus large
possible deux militants de greenpeace
prennent d'assaut le clemenceau qu'il
juge hautement toxiques yannick jadot la
fin justifie t'elle tous les moyens pas
tous les moyens jamais la violence
[Musique]
7 heures du matin autour du rainbow
warrior la bataille navale que commencer
et parfois des actions peuvent faire
évoluer la loi dans le sens de l'intérêt
général c'est complètement fou c'est que
ils nous balancent des boulons que la
gendarmerie est là à 100 m et qu'elle ne
fait absolument rien fait d illégal mais
ça correspond toujours souhaits des
citoyens et donc c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]